This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, Portlandia fans. Carrie Brownstein and Fred Armisen here. The Dream of the 90s is alive in podcast form. We're launching Podlandia, AEO, rewatch, our brand new podcast where we revisit every episode of Portlandia together, breaking down sketches, going deep on our iconic characters,
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证真人。嘿，Portlandia的粉丝们。我是Carrie Brownstein和Fred Armisen。90年代的梦想在播客形式中依然活着。我们正在推出Podlandia，AEO，重温，这是我们的全新播客，我们将一起重温Portlandia的每一集，剖析短剧，深入探讨我们的标志性角色，
and pulling back the curtain on how it all got made. And we'll also be joined by the people who helped bring it all to life. Guest stars, collaborators, and friends, including director Jonathan Chrysler, the mayor himself, Kyle McLaughlin, legendary musician Amy Mann, and many more. Kyle is going for it here. You fully improvised, not just words, but a song about it.
并揭开这一切是如何制作的幕后。我们还将邀请那些帮助将其变为现实的人们加入。嘉宾明星、合作者和朋友，包括导演Jonathan Chrysler、市长本人Kyle McLaughlin、传奇音乐家Amy Mann等等。凯尔在这里全力以赴。你完全即兴发挥，不仅是台词，还有关于它的歌曲。
Well, I thought you were all going to write a song. I remember you thinking that. Listen to Podlandia. A.A.O. Rewatch on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. What's up, fam? I'm sports journalist Ari Chambers. Hey, what's up, y'all? It's your girl, Sam J. And we're the host of everyone watches women's sports.
嗯，我以为你们都会写一首歌。我记得你是这么想的。收听Podlandia。A.A.O. 在IHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方重温。最近怎么样，家人们？我是体育记者Ari Chambers。嘿，你们好吗？我是你们的女孩Sam J。我们是每个人都在看女子体育的节目主持人。
It's a new podcast from Together in I Heart Women's Sports. We're breaking down the biggest headlines. Naomi Osaka, showing out. Shout-hous to you, Naomi. The viral moments. I've been obsessed with Kashan Rock's boxing journey. She looks good. Her combos are swift.
这是来自Together in I Heart Women's Sports的一个新播客。我们正在剖析最大的头条新闻。大坂直美，表现出色。向你致敬，大坂直美。病毒式传播的时刻。我一直沉迷于Kashan Rock的拳击之旅。她看起来不错。她的组合拳很敏捷。
And the stories everyone's talking about across women's sports. Because everyone watches women's sports. Listen to everyone watches women's sports on the IHeart Radio app. Apple Podcast or wherever you get your podcast. I'm Nick Titoro. You probably know me from NYPD Blue, the longest yard, or Spike Least Black Klansman. And on my new podcast, Delivering Happiness with Nick Tatoro, I deliver pizza to a new guest.
以及每个人都在谈论的女子体育故事。因为每个人都在看女子体育。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听每个人都在看女子体育。我是Nick Titoro。你可能从《纽约重案组》、《最长的一码》或斯派克·李的《黑色党徒》中认识我。在我的新播客《与Nick Tatoro一起传递幸福》中，我给一位新嘉宾送披萨。
I've shared a slice with everyone from Seth Rollins. What are you doing? My belt. To Bill Burr. I don't think I've ever met somebody so exactly out of their mind as I am. And now, we even have more great guests coming up, including the great John Tuturo. It's called Happiness. Delivering Happiness.
我跟从Seth Rollins到Bill Burr的每个人分享了一片披萨。你在干什么？我的腰带。致Bill Burr。我想我从来没见过哪个人的疯狂程度和我一模一样。现在，我们甚至还有更多伟大的嘉宾即将到来，包括伟大的John Tuturo。它叫幸福。传递幸福。
And many, many more. Open your free High Heart Radio app. Search Delivering Happiness with Nick Tutro. And listen now. This is Chelsea Handler from Bill. Dear Chelsea, every week the news gets worse. The world gets crazier, and Yamanika is here to tell whoever's responsible, you're the problem. Do you know I just found out who Sidney Sweeney was?
还有很多很多。打开你免费的High Heart Radio应用。搜索《与Nick Tutro一起传递幸福》。现在就收听。我是来自Bill的Chelsea Handler。亲爱的切尔西，每周新闻都在恶化。世界变得越来越疯狂，Yamanika在这里告诉任何负责的人，你才是问题所在。你知道我刚发现Sidney Sweeney是谁吗？
If he got a bunch of women, then I should have a bunch of men. Do better or do less, so I don't have to do so much. I'm Yamanika, and I'm out. Listen to You're the Problem with Yamanika on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. I'm Jake Brennan. and on my podcast, Disgraceland, I tell the stories behind music's biggest names, like how the story of the foo fighters
如果他有一群女人，那么我也应该有一群男人。做得更好或者做得少一些，这样我就不用做那么多了。我是Yamanika，我退出了。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听Yamanika的《你就是问题所在》。我是Jake Brennan。在我的播客Disgraceland中，我讲述了音乐界最大牌明星背后的故事，比如Foo Fighters的故事
isn't just about music, it's about grief, shock, in the moment everything changed. Imagine that. You're in the biggest band on the planet, as Dave Grohl was in 1994 in Nirvana, and the phone rings, and you learn that your singer, your friend,
不仅仅是关于音乐，它是关于悲伤、震惊以及一切改变的那一刻。想象一下。你身处地球上最大的乐队，正如Dave Grohl在1994年在Nirvana中一样，电话铃响了，你得知你的歌手、你的朋友，
the reluctant voice of a generation, Kurt Cobain, is dead. Listen to Disgraceland on the Iy iHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. I'm Jemma Spake and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology.
一个时代的艰难发声者，Kurt Cobain，已经去世了。在iHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听Disgraceland。大家好。我是Jemma Spake，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们讨论二十岁时最大的变化、时刻和过渡，以及它们对我们心理学的意义。
This episode is a rerun. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. Thank you so much for joining us back here for another episode as we break down the psychology of our 20s. I have a bit of a different episode for you all today. I know you all love our deep dives and our really, like, in-depth searches for the science behind,
这一集是重播。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。新听众，老听众，无论你在世界的哪个角落。非常感谢你回到这里收听另一集，我们一起剖析二十岁的心理学。今天我为大家准备了一个稍微不同的节目。我知道大家都喜欢我们的深度挖掘和对背后科学的真正深入搜索，
obviously the experiences of our 20s. But today, I want to do something a little bit different and not just focus on one topic for this episode, but talk through a bit of a list. In fact, a list that I have been working on for the past month, basically just outlining the biggest mistakes that people make in their 20s, from people still in their 20s all the way up to people who I've spoken to in their 70s and their 80s. I've talked to so many people just kind of sliding in this question into conversation and writing down their answers.
显然是关于我们二十岁的经历。但今天，我想做点不一样的，不仅仅专注于这一集的某个话题，而是通过一个清单来谈谈。事实上，这个清单我过去一个月一直在整理，基本上只是概述了人们在二十岁时犯下的最大错误，从仍在二十岁的人一直到我交谈过的七十多岁和八十多岁的人。我跟这么多人交谈过，只是把这个问题塞进谈话中并写下他们的回答。
What's the biggest mistake that? you made during this decade. I even put up a bit of a question box on Instagram. Over 5,000 of you responded or emailed me or DM'd me or dropped a comment in an episode and having curated and putting together that whole list, I want to share some of my very basic findings and, you know, take that list out of my Excel spreadsheet and just share this little personal research project with you guys. the 20 most common mistakes that people say they made in their 20s.
最大的错误是什么？你在十年间做出的。我甚至在Instagram上发布了一个问题箱。你们有5000多人回复、发邮件、发私信或在剧集下留言，在策划并整理了整个清单后，我想分享一些我非常基础的发现，你知道，把那个清单从我的Excel电子表格中拿出来，与大家分享这个小型个人研究项目。人们说他们在二十岁时犯下的20个最常见错误。
You know, in doing this, I kind of had to stop and pause a few times and be like, huh, is this a mistake that I'm maybe currently making? Like, what can I learn from this? What can I learn from these people's experiences? I feel like we're in such a confusing decade of life. And all we really want is someone to give us the answers or for someone to give us, you know, some kind of reassurance that we are doing the right thing and that we're on the right path. Unfortunately for us, obviously, no one can tell you if what you're doing is correct.
你知道，在做这件事的时候，我不得不停下来暂停几次，心里想，哈，这是我目前可能正在犯的错误吗？比如，我能从中学到什么？我能从这些人的经历中学到什么？我觉得我们正处于生活如此令人困惑的十年中。我们真正想要的只是有人给我们答案，或者有人给我们，你知道，某种保证，证明我们做对了，我们在正确的道路上。不幸的是，很显然，没有人能告诉你你做的是否正确。
And they can't tell you what's going to happen next. And they can't tell you that you're not going to have regrets, but they can share their own mistakes and their own misturns and kind of hope that you learn from them. What really inspired me to do this was actually a 2012 publication titled The Five Regrets of the dying. And these regrets were, I wished I'd had the courage to live a life true to myself. I wish that I hadn't worked so hard. I wish I'd had the courage to express my feelings. I wish I'd stayed in touch with my friends and I'd wish I'd let myself be happier. These were the regrets of people reflecting on, you know, their whole entire lives. But I wondered
他们无法告诉你接下来会发生什么。他们无法告诉你你不会后悔，但他们可以分享他们自己的错误和弯路，并希望你能从中吸取教训。真正启发我做这件事的实际上是2012年出版的一篇名为《临终前的五个遗憾》的文章。这些遗憾是，我希望我有勇气过忠于自己的生活。我希望我没有那么拼命工作。我希望我有勇气表达我的感受。我希望我跟朋友保持联系，我希望我能让自己更快乐。这些是人们反思自己整个人生时的遗憾。但我一直在想
if we could make kind of like a decade-specific list to learn from as we go along. So this is that kind of preliminary list. Without further ado, my lovely listeners, there is so much to cover, so much info, and of course, a little bit of psychology. Thank you to every single one of you who shared their regrets, shared their mistakes, whether I talk to you in person, whether you DM to me. However, you got the information across. It has been truly valuable. I can't wait to get into it. You've heard the chaos. Now you can see it. Do we want to jump right in?
如果我们能做一个十年特定清单来供我们前进时学习就好了。所以这就是那种初步清单。废话不多说，我可爱的听众们，有太多内容要涵盖，有太多信息，当然还有一点点心理学。感谢每一个分享了他们遗憾、分享了他们错误的人，无论我是亲自跟你谈，还是你发私信给我。无论你如何传达信息。这真的是非常有价值的。我迫不及待地想深入探讨了。你已经听过了混乱。现在你可以看到了。我们想直接开始吗？
Watch all your favorite podcasts from start to finish right inside the free IHard Radio app. Make some noise. Wooee! Catch every laugh and eye roll on shows like Bestie Listen, Hey Jonas, and Las Culturistas. Now with full video. I'll just leave that there.
在免费的IHard Radio应用内，从头到尾观看你所有最喜欢的播客。制造点动静。Wooee! 在像《Bestie Listen》、《Hey Jonas》和《Las Culturistas》这样的节目中捕捉每一个笑声和翻白眼。现在有完整视频。我把这个留在那儿。
It's the same hosts and the same chemistry with all the hilarious moments you've been missing right on your screen. Open the free IHR. Radio app. Search video podcasts and tap watch. What's up, fam? I'm sports journalist Ari Chambers. Hey, what's up, y'all?
这是相同的主持人和相同的化学反应，你一直错过的所有搞笑时刻就在你的屏幕上。打开免费的IHR。Radio应用。搜索视频播客并点击观看。最近怎么样，家人们？我是体育记者Ari Chambers。嘿，你们好吗？
It's your girl, Sam J. And we're the host of everyone watches women's sports, a new podcast from Together and I Heart Women's Sports. Because let's be real. Women's sports is giving us way too much to talk about these days. So Kelsey Finler, she became the first female solo rower to go from California to Hawaii. My first thought is, like, what's up with the snacks? Like, what are we eating?
这是你们的女孩Sam J。我们是每个人都在看女子体育的节目主持人，这是一个来自Together and I Heart Women's Sports的新播客。因为说实话。女子体育这些天给我们提供了太多谈资。所以Kelsey Finler，她成为了第一个从加利福尼亚独自划船到夏威夷的女性。我的第一反应是，零食怎么说？比如，我们在吃什么？
The highlights, the rivalries, the breakout stars, the moments that take over your entire timeline. And the conversations that start during the game and somehow, keep going all week. Every week, we're breaking down the biggest stories across women's sports. Naomi Osaka, showing out, she beat Sabalinka. Shout out to you, Naomi. You get the palm, Naomi. You get the palm for that. Because we're not just interested in what happened. We're interested in why everyone's talking about it. Because everyone watches women's sports. Listen to everyone watches women's sports. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
集锦、竞争、突出的明星、占领你整个时间线的时刻。以及在比赛期间开始并在整周不知何故继续的对话。每周，我们都在剖析女子体育最大的故事。大坂直美，表现出色，她击败了萨巴伦卡。向你致敬，大坂直美。你得到了手掌，大坂直美。你因此得到了手掌。因为我们不仅对发生了什么感兴趣。我们对为什么每个人都在谈论它感兴趣。因为每个人都在看女子体育。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听每个人都在看女子体育。
Hey, Portlandia fans. Carrie Brownstein and Fred Armisen here. You know us or rather you know them. Tony and Candice, Nina and Lance, Spike, and yes, The Chicken. We've played a lot of iconic characters over the years, but today we're showing up as ourselves to tell you about Podlandia, AEO rewatch, our brand new podcast. Each week, we'll revisit an episode of Portlandia from the very beginning, breaking down the sketches, exploring the backstories of our most iconic characters, revisiting the Portland locations you know and love, and opening up about our creative process.
嘿，Portlandia的粉丝们。我是Carrie Brownstein和Fred Armisen。你们认识我们，或者更确切地说，你们认识他们。Tony和Candice，Nina和Lance，Spike，还有，是的，The Chicken。这些年来我们扮演了许多标志性的角色，但今天我们以自己身份出现，向大家介绍Podlandia，AEO重温，我们的全新播客。每周，我们都会从头开始重温一集Portlandia，剖析短剧，探索我们最具标志性角色的背景故事，重温你熟知和喜爱的波特兰地点，并公开我们的创作过程。
How did any of this get made? Why do we think that was a good idea? We're ready to talk about it. And we'll also be joined by the people who helped bring it all to life. Guestrars, collaborators and friends, including director Jonathan Chryssel, the mayor himself, Kyle McLaughlin, legendary musician Amy Mann, and many more. Kyle is going for it here. You fully improvised, not just words, but a song, a melody.
这一切到底是怎么制作出来的？为什么我们觉得那是个好主意？我们准备好谈论它了。我们还将邀请那些帮助将其变为现实的人们加入。嘉宾明星、合作者和朋友，包括导演Jonathan Chryssel、市长本人Kyle McLaughlin、传奇音乐家Amy Mann等等。凯尔在这里全力以赴。你完全即兴发挥，不仅是台词，还有一首歌，一段旋律。
Well, I thought he was going to write. I thought you were going to write a song. I remember you thinking that. Listen to Podlandia. Ayo, rewatch on the IHeartRadio, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you can. get your podcasts. I'm Nick Totoro. You probably know me from NYPD Blue,
嗯，我以为他会写。我以为你会写一首歌。我记得你是这么想的。收听Podlandia。Ayo，在IHeartRadio、苹果播客上重温，或者无论你在哪里。获取你的播客。我是Nick Totoro。你可能从《纽约重案组》认识我，
the longest yard, or Spike Lee's Black Klansman. But I'm also from Queens, which means I know pizza. And on my new podcast, delivering happiness with Nick Totoro, I deliver pizza from Prince Street pizza to a new guest.
《最长的一码》或斯派克·李的《黑色党徒》。但我也来自皇后区，这意味着我懂披萨。在我的新播客《与Nick Totoro一起传递幸福》中，我把Prince Street披萨店的披萨送给一位新嘉宾。
Are you delivering pizza now? Then we sit down for a real conversation. I've shared a slice with everyone, from Seth Rollins. What are you doing, my belt? To Alex Rodriguez. Just to let you people know, we're talking to one of the goats here.
你现在在送披萨吗？然后我们坐下来进行真正的对话。我跟每个人分享了一片披萨，从Seth Rollins。你在干什么，我的腰带？到Alex Rodriguez。只是让你们知道，我们在这里跟其中一个山羊（史上最佳）交谈。
To Bill Burr. I don't think I've ever met somebody so exactly out of their mind as I am. And now, we even have more great guests coming up, including the great John Tuturo. It's called Happiness, Delivering Happiness. Mariano Rivera. Oh, my God. And many, many more. Open your free High Heart Radio app.
到Bill Burr。我想我从来没见过哪个人的疯狂程度和我一模一样。现在，我们甚至还有更多伟大的嘉宾即将到来，包括伟大的John Tuturo。它叫幸福，传递幸福。Mariano Rivera。哦，天哪。还有很多很多。打开你免费的High Heart Radio应用。
Search Delivering Happiness with Nick Totoro. And listen now. This is Chelsea handler from Dear Chelsea. Every week, the news gets worse. The world gets crazier. And Yamanika is here to tell whoever's responsible your. the problem. If you come over here to play games, I'ma
搜索《与Nick Totoro一起传递幸福》。现在就收听。我是来自亲爱的切尔西的Chelsea handler。每周，新闻都在变得更糟。世界变得越来越疯狂。Yamanika在这里告诉任何负有责任的人，你是。问题所在。如果你到这里来玩游戏，我会
check you. Okay? If you do some in the news that don't sound good, I'm going to play you. Join Yomeneka Saunders as she breaks down the week's most problematic stories on her new podcast. You're the problem with Yamanika. Do you know I just found out who Sidney
检查你。好吗？如果你在新闻中做了一些听起来不太好的事情，我要调侃你。加入Yomeneka Saunders，在她全新的播客《Yamanika的你就是问题所在》中剖析本周最具问题的故事。你知道我刚刚发现Sidney是谁吗
was? New episodes weekly every Wednesday is part of my new network, the dear Chelsea Network. If he got a bunch of women, then I should have a bunch of men. Do better or do less so I don't have to do so much. So join Yamanika each episode as she answers one question. Who's the problem?
什么？每周三更新的新节目是我新网络“亲爱的切尔西网络”的一部分。如果他有一群女人，那么我也应该有一群男人。要么做得更好，要么少做一点，这样我就不用做那么多了。所以，每期节目都来和亚玛尼卡一起回答一个问题：谁才是问题所在？
I'm Yamanika and I'm out. Listen to you're the problem with Yamanika on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. So let me start by clarifying that this list is by no means like a peer-reviewed study. Like if I submitted this very basic. research to like any journal or any publication, you know, I would be rejected in a heartbeat. You know, this was more of a personal interest project for me that kind of turned into this much bigger thing because I spent obviously a lot of time thinking about my 20s. But what I found does kind of seem to line up with what I thought I was going to find,
我是亚玛尼卡，我先走一步。请在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听亚玛尼卡主持的《你才是问题所在》。那么，我首先要澄清的是，这份清单绝不是什么经过同行评审的研究。就像如果我把这份非常基础的研究提交给任何期刊或出版物，你知道的，我肯定会毫不犹豫地被拒绝。你知道的，这对我来说更像是一个个人兴趣项目，它有点演变成了一件更大事情，因为我显然花了很多时间思考我的20多岁。但我发现的事情确实与我原本以为会发现的相吻合，
basically. So I do think that although I wasn't able to get, you know, a sample. or like a random sample and I wasn't able to talk to even more people than I would have wanted and I wasn't able to, you know, apply for an ethics application or do anything like that. This list still has a lot of value. But take it with a grain of salt. If you don't necessarily agree with some of the things on this list, that's totally okay. If you think that we've missed things on this list, also please feel free to leave a comment below because, yes, it's not as comprehensive as I would have liked it to be, but still very, very fascinating.
基本上是这样。所以我觉得，虽然我没能获得样本，或者说随机样本，而且我没能和比我预期更多的人交流，我也没能申请伦理审批或做类似的事情。这份清单仍然有很多价值。但请对它保持保留态度。如果你不一定同意这份清单上的某些事情，那完全没关系。如果你认为我们漏掉了这份清单上的某些东西，也请随时在下方留言，因为，是的，它不像我希望的那样全面，但依然非常非常迷人。
With that in mind, I want to begin by talking about mistake number one. The biggest mistake that people talked about time and time again. I'm going to give you a second to guess what that was. So by far the biggest mistake that I heard that people made in their 20s was prioritizing a romantic relationship over my friends, over my career, over my personal growth. essentially people talking about how they had put romantic attraction at the center of everything that they did and kind of realized later along down the line that it meant that a lot of the other things that matter to them kind of got pushed to the sidelines. I heard this so often in so many different forms as well.
带着这一点，我想从谈论第一个错误开始。人们一次又一次谈论的最大错误。我给你们一秒钟的时间去猜那是什么。到目前为止，我听到人们在20多岁时犯下的最大错误是，将恋爱关系置于我的朋友、我的事业和我的个人成长之上。本质上，人们谈论他们如何将对浪漫的吸引力置于他们所做一切的中心，并在后来的一段时间里意识到，这意味着许多对他们重要的事情最终都被边缘化了。我经常以各种不同的形式听到这种说法。
Someone talked about how they had left a job that I loved for a man who dumped them five days later or people who had lost friends because they didn't make time for them when they were with their ex or being so focused on finding love at 21, 22, 23 that they never spent time growing as a person and learning what they really loved about themselves. These were just a few kind of versions of the same mistake that I heard. And you know what? I relate to this very, very deeply. I remember being 19, 20, just like desperately wanting to be chosen.
有人谈到他们如何为了一个在五天后甩了他们的男人而离开了一份我热爱的工作，或者有人因为和前任在一起时没有留出时间陪伴朋友而失去了朋友，或者在21、22、23岁时如此专注于寻找真爱，以至于他们从来没有花时间作为一个人去成长，去了解他们真正热爱自己的什么。这些只是我听到的同一种错误的几个版本。你知道吗？我对此有着非常非常深刻的共鸣。我记得自己19岁、20岁的时候，就像疯狂地渴望被选择一样。
chosen by someone, you know, at a club, at a party, on a dating app. It became such an obsession that what I thought was love became my only priority and everything else in my life kind of suffered. I just wish I could tell that version of myself, you know, from only like five, seven years ago just to slow down a little bit, like just to have some fun. Treat dating like an experiment. Treat dating like you're studying humankind and figuring out what you like. and what you don't and what works for you and what kind of person elevates your life rather than just
渴望被某人选择，你知道的，在俱乐部里，在派对上，在约会软件上。这成了一种强迫症，以至于我曾经认为是爱的东西成了我唯一的首要任务，而我生活中的其他一切都因此受到了影响。我真希望自己能告诉那个阶段的自己，你知道的，仅仅是五、七年前的自己，放慢一点脚步，比如好好享受一下乐趣。把约会当作一场实验。把约会当作你在研究人类，弄清楚你喜欢什么，不喜欢什么，什么对你有效，以及什么样的人能提升你的生活，而不是仅仅
kind of to use this analogy jumping in the first cab off the rank and hoping that it's the right one and kind of later on finding that it probably wasn't. You guys know that I did a bit of a dating detox in my early 20s where I didn't date, I didn't have dating apps, I didn't think really about men for almost half a year and it was during that time that I can firmly say my career took off. I made more friends and incredible friends more than I really think I'd ever had. I really fell in love with myself. And now that I am in a relationship and we live together, we have a dog together, it feels like the right thing.
用这个比喻来说，就像跳上排队的第一辆出租车，希望它是对的那辆，然后过了一段时间发现它可能并不是。你们知道我在20多岁出头的时候做过一次约会排毒，我当时不约会，没有约会软件，有将近半年的时间我几乎不考虑男人，正是在那段时间里，我可以肯定地说我的事业起飞了。我结交了更多的朋友，而且是比我以往任何时候都要多的不可思议的朋友。我真的爱上了自己。现在我处于一段恋爱关系中，我们同居了，我们一起养了一只狗，这感觉是正确的事情。
And it feels like actually that relationship is not my whole world, when I used to make relationships my whole world. How I think about it is like, here's this separate universe for me that I can step into and enjoy alongside and. and in parallel to this life that I've built myself. Like, my whole world is a life that is more than just love. So if you will want to avoid what seems like a very big regret or mistake for many people, treat love as something that is fantastic if it finds you.
而且感觉实际上那段关系并不是我的全部世界，而我以前总是把恋爱关系当作我的全部世界。我是这样想的：对我来说，这是一个独立的宇宙，我可以走进并享受它，它与我为自己建立的生活并行不悖。就像，我的全部世界不仅仅是爱情。所以，如果你想避免对许多人来说是一个巨大遗憾或错误的事情，把爱当作一种如果它找到你就会非常棒的东西，
But not everything, especially during this decade, should revolve around it. I heard this analogy the other day that I love. if you knew you would meet the love of your life in six months, how would you live those next six months to the fullest as a single person? And yes, you might not actually meet them in six months, but aim to live like every single day, every single week in that same mindset and with that same perspective for as long as you can. That's mistake number one. Similar to that mistake, another one that was very closely related and came in second was people who talked about staying in a relationship when they knew it wasn't right for them.
但并非一切，尤其是在这十年里，都应该围绕它旋转。我前几天听到这个比喻，我非常喜欢。如果你知道你会在六个月后遇到你一生的挚爱，作为一个单身人士，你将如何充实地过好这接下来的六个月？是的，你可能实际上不会在六个月后遇到他们，但目标是尽可能长地带着那种心态和视角，像过好每一天、每一个星期一样去生活。那是第一个错误。与那个错误相似的是，另一个密切相关并排在第二位的错误是，人们在明知一段感情不适合自己时，依然选择坚持下去。
That was the second biggest mistake that I heard. This isn't so much about centering the pursuit of love in your life. It's more so about people who found a love that they thought worked and held onto it perhaps for longer than they should have. A lot of these people talked about either A, knowing very early on that this person wasn't for them and not acting sooner, or be, you know, not even knowing that and not even knowing how to act at all. Not knowing and having doubts whether, like doubting your doubts,
那是我听到的第二大错误。这与其说是关于将对爱情的追求置于你生活中心，不如说是关于那些找到了他们认为行之有效的爱情并将其紧紧抓住的人，其持续时间可能比他们应该坚持的时间更长。这些人中的许多人谈到，要么是A，很早就知道这个人不适合自己却没有早点采取行动，要么是B，你知道的，甚至不知道这一点，甚至根本不知道该怎么做。不知道并心存疑虑，比如怀疑自己的疑虑，
doubting whether your perception of this person was correct for so long that by the time you knew that they weren't, you really didn't know even how to change things. You were living together, you had pets together, maybe you were even married, you had kids together and just not knowing how to pull out of that relationship. when things finally end, quite a number of people spoke about how it felt like they'd kind of wasted their youth, they have to start all over again, and how they, you know, maybe didn't completely regret the relationship, but definitely kind of wanted some of those years back. You do have to give yourself a lot of grace in these situations, though, because whether someone
怀疑自己对这个人的看法是否正确了太久，以至于当你终于知道他们不合适时，你真的甚至不知道该如何改变现状。你们住在一起，你们一起养宠物，也许你们甚至结婚了，你们有了孩子，只是不知道该如何从那段关系中抽身。当事情终于结束时，相当多的人谈到这感觉像是浪费了青春，他们不得不一切从头开始，以及他们，你知道的，可能并不完全后悔这段感情，但绝对有点想找回那些年。不过在这些情况下，你必须对自己多一点宽容，因为无论是谁
is right for you or not is actually a really tricky question to answer. Like, how do you really not? How can you really trust that that instinct isn't just relationship anxiety or relationship OCD or just general anxiety? Personally, I think it's really, really hard because relationships are tricky sometimes. Like every single relationship is going to have its trials. And knowing whether that's a deal breaker or just something that you have to get through is kind of difficult to understand when maybe this is like your first relationship or, you know, you haven't had the most healthy example. of what healthy love looks like, you kind of just assume that this must be it. Also, just to add to this, if you're someone who has always had a specific timeline for your life kind of imposed upon you
是否适合你其实是一个很难回答的问题。比如，你怎么能真的不知道？你怎么能真正相信那种直觉不仅仅是恋爱焦虑或恋爱强迫症，或者只是一般的焦虑？就我个人而言，我觉得这真的非常非常难，因为有时候恋爱很棘手。就像每一段感情都会经历考验一样。当你这可能是你的初夜，或者你知道，你没有拥有最健康的示范，不知道什么是健康的爱时，去了解这到底是一个原则问题还是只是你需要度过的一个难关是很困难的，你可能只会假设这一定就是这样。另外，顺便补充一下，如果你是一个一直对自己的生活有着特定时间线的人，这种时间线是被强加给你的
by society, by parents, by culture, if you're someone who struggles being alone, it can be a lot easier to settle for good enough in order to fill that void or fill that expectation and only realize like a lot later down the line that you've made a mistake. Okay, we're going to move on from the romance and love mistakes and talk finances. A big number of the mistakes that people relayed that they made in their 20s related to money. Here are the three that came up the most, in no certain order, just the three that were very, very common. The first one was not saving. The second one was not investing sooner. And the third mistake. mistake was getting a credit card. The savings one was huge. One quote from a listener that really
由社会、父母、文化，如果你是一个难以独处的人，为了填补那个空白或满足那种期望，将就着接受一个“差不多”的人会容易得多，直到很久以后才意识到自己犯了错误。好了，我们要从浪漫和爱情的错误转向谈论财务。人们在20多岁时犯下的很大一部分错误都与金钱有关。以下是出现频率最高的三项，没有特定的顺序，只是非常非常普遍的三项。第一项是没有存钱。第二项是没有更早地投资。第三个错误是办了一张信用卡。储蓄的那一项非常巨大。听众的一句话真的
stood out was this. Yes, money does come and go, but experiences last forever and that matters, but you also need to support yourself to have those experiences. The stress I put myself through to go to festivals, to have a Euro summer when I couldn't afford it, to go out for dinner, to buy new clothes was not worth it. I wish I knew what I knew now and had saved more. We can learn a lot from that. When it comes to saving and investing, I beg of you, please just choose like one day this month to sit down and freshen up on your financial literacy. You don't have to have a lot of money to know how your money works and what it can do for you.
很突出：是的，钱是身外之物，但经历是永恒的，这很重要，但你也需要养活自己才能拥有那些体验。为了去音乐节、为了在我负担不起的时候去欧洲过夏天、为了出去吃大晚餐、为了买新衣服而给自己施加的压力根本不值得。我希望我能早点知道现在所知道的，并存下更多的钱。我们可以从中学到很多东西。当谈到储蓄和投资时，我恳求你们，请选择本月的一天坐下来，重温一下你们的金融理财知识。你不需要有很多钱就能了解你的钱是如何运作的以及它能为你做些什么。
You don't have to have a lot of money before you start. Like, you don't actually have to invest. You don't actually have to do anything with that information. It's just important that you know this stuff early in your 20s. when it's easier to learn and to kind of decide what you want financially for your future. I'll be honest, I put this off for so long. And it was only a couple of months ago that I did really have to say to myself, like, enough.
在你开始之前，你不需要有很多钱。就像，你其实不需要投资。你其实不需要对这些信息做任何事情。重要的是，你在20多岁时就要早点了解这些东西，这时学习起来更容易，而且能决定你对未来财务的期望。说实话，我把这件事推迟了很久。直到几个月前，我才真正对自己说，够了。
I have to get my money together. I have to learn how investing works, what budget is best, which bank to be with, how to use different accounts and point systems and high interest accounts and whatnot. And I just dedicated like two days across like a two month period, to just learning and listening to podcasts and reading articles and following people who talked about this. And it did make me feel so much more secure and knowledgeable. It definitely eased a lot of anxiety that I had around my future with my money.
我必须把我的财务状况整理好。我必须了解投资是如何运作的，什么样的预算最好，应该选择哪家银行，如何使用不同的账户、积分系统和高息账户等等。我在两个月的时间里抽出了两天时间，专门用来学习、听播客、读文章以及关注谈论这些事情的人。这确实让我感到更有安全感、更有知识储备。它绝对缓解了我对金钱未来的许多焦虑。
And I'm going to express that same sentiment that the woman who DM'd me said, I definitely wish that when I was 23 or even younger, I knew what I knew now because it definitely could have saved me a lot of money and saved me a lot of stress and probably impacted my future in a way that I'm probably not ready to even think about, like having that extra money in like my savings or in my super account, my retirement fund. I try not to think about the opportunities that I missed out on not doing that earlier. There are also so many different ways to budget. Like some people use the 50, 30, 20, 20 method. So 50% for needs, 30% for once, 20% for savings. Others like the 70, 20, 10 method. some people give themselves like a maximum amount each month that they can spend and everything else
我要表达那位给我发私信的女士所说的同一种情感，我绝对希望自己在23岁甚至更年轻的时候就知道我现在所知道的，因为这绝对可以为我省下一大笔钱，省下很多压力，并可能以一种我甚至还没准备好去想的方式影响我的未来，比如在我的储蓄或超级账户、我的退休基金里拥有那笔额外的钱。我尽量不去想因为没有早点这样做而错过的机会。预算也有很多不同的方法。比如有些人使用50-30-20法。所以50%用于需求，30%用于欲望，20%用于储蓄。其他人喜欢70-20-10法。有些人给自己设定了每个月可以花销的最高金额，剩下的所有
goes into savings and they don't touch that whatever it is find something that works and start even when it feels intimidating as for that third financial mistake i regret getting a credit card take that advice seriously credit cards are great for building a credit score and finding ways to get money back and perks and travel points, but my rule has always been and it will continue to be. If I don't need it and I can't afford it, I don't need it. Only buy things with a credit card that you can hopefully pay off immediately. Obviously there are some big purchases like buying a house or a car where it's a bit different, but in terms of just like everyday wants like clothes, like travel, like homewares, like whatever it is, if you don't need it and you can't afford it, you don't
都存起来，而且绝对不去动它，不管是什么方法，找到一个行之有效的方法并开始行动，即使这让人感到令人生畏。至于第三个财务错误，我后悔办了一张信用卡，请认真对待这个建议。信用卡对于建立信用评分、寻找返现途径、福利以及旅游积分非常棒，但我的规则一直是，也将继续是：如果我不需要，而且我买不起，那我就不需要它。用信用卡只能买那些你希望能够立即还清的东西。显然有些大宗采购，比如买房子或买车，情况有点不同，但就日常的需求而言，比如衣服、旅行、家居用品，不管是什么，如果你不需要，而且你买不起，你就不
need it. I actually found a study that concluded around two-thirds of people in their 20s have credit card debt. And another publication was saying that the average amount of that debt is around $6,000. $6,000. That's scary stuff. And if you don't know what you're doing to get that debt down, that can follow you. If you don't know how to correctly use a credit card as a tool rather than as a lifeline, it can get you into a lot of danger. So reflect on those mistakes. Do what you wish with that knowledge. Moving on, there was another group of mistakes that I heard time and time again, and they have to do with how we let others' thoughts, opinions, and actions affect us. Mistake number six was putting people's needs above my own. Another one high up on that list,
需要它。我实际上发现了一项研究，其结论是大约三分之二的20多岁的人都有信用卡债务。另一家出版物称，这种债务的平均金额约为6,000美元。6,000美元。这真是太可怕了。如果你不知道自己在做什么来减少这些债务，这会一直缠着你。如果你不知道如何正确地将信用卡作为一种工具，而不是作为救命稻草，它会让你陷入很大的危险之中。所以反思这些错误。用这些知识做你想做的事。接下来，我一次又一次地听到另一类错误，它们与我们如何让别人的想法、意见和行动影响我们有关。第六个错误是把别人的需求置于我自己的需求之上。名单上名列前茅的另一个错误是，
not learning to say no. And finally, worrying too much about what people thought of me. All kind of in the same vein, I would say. Let me say. Let me say. this, how you think about yourself, how you treat yourself, what you learn to tolerate and not tolerate when it comes to other people's behavior, that has a much bigger impact than we think. And it definitely snowballs. Like it may be small in the moment to just say yes and to just kind of be passive in the face of someone else's assertions. We may not even notice it, but it can shape our whole life. If we end up being steered in a direction that we didn't want to go to make other people happy. Maybe that's like choosing a certain career.
没有学会说不。最后，过分在意别人对我的看法。可以说，这都属于同一种调调。让我这样说。让我这样说。你如何看待自己，你如何对待自己，当面对别人的行为时你学会容忍什么、不容忍什么，这比我们想象的有着大得多的影响。而且它绝对像滚雪球一样。比如在当时顺口答应并对别人的断言表现得被动，可能只是一件小事。我们甚至可能没有注意到它，但它可以塑造我们的整个人生。如果我们最终被引导朝着我们并不想去地方前进，只是为了让别人开心。也许那是选择特定的职业。
Maybe that is earlier like choosing a certain partner that you think will meet your parents' expectations. Maybe it's just letting friends treat you badly. That does something to your soul and it does something to your sense of self that can be harder to repair the older we get. And I also think the older we get, the more we realize that life is really, really finite and you only really get one shot and you owe it to yourself to be fierce. to really stand up for yourself. You know, at the end of the day, when you're looking back, you want to feel like you were in control
也许更早的时候是选择一个你认为符合你父母期望的特定伴侣。也许只是让朋友虐待你。这会对你的灵魂产生影响，也会对你的自我意识产生影响，随着年龄的增长，这种影响会变得更难修复。而且我也认为，随着年龄的增长，我们越发意识到生命真的非常有限，你真的只有一次机会，你欠自己一份勇气，去真正为自己挺身而出。你知道的，到头来，当你回首往事时，你会希望自己觉得一切尽在掌握，
and you didn't continuously sacrifice your own happiness for someone else's comfort, especially when they don't even end up appreciating it. Let me say, a lot of the time, these reactions are instinctual. So I don't want you to feel like there's shame around having done this or this being something you want to unlearn. A lot of the time, these actions aren't just
而不是为了别人的舒适而不断牺牲自己的快乐，尤其是当他们甚至不领情的时候。让我说，很多时候，这些反应是本能的。所以我不希望你因为做过这些事或者这是你想改掉的东西而感到羞耻。很多时候，这些行动不仅是
insincial they were also conditioned over many years since we were children to be, you know, good and to be agreeable and to just let others have their way or have their say. It is your job to deliberately unlearn these mechanisms. It is your job at some stage in your life to unlearn your tendency to shrink or to make yourself small. And it will be uncomfortable at first. You know, it is uncomfortable to upset people. It is uncomfortable to hear mean things or to disappoint people or to say no. Of course it's uncomfortable because you're not used to doing it.
本能的，它们还在多年里经过了我们的长期规训，从我们还是孩子的时候起，就要做一个好孩子，要随和，要任由别人按他们的意愿行事或发表意见。你的工作是有意识地戒除这些机制。你在人生的某个阶段的工作，就是戒除那种不断萎缩或让自己变小的倾向。一开始会很不舒服。你知道的，惹恼别人是不舒服的。听到刻薄的话、让人失望或说不都是不舒服的。当然不舒服，因为你习惯了不这么做。
But on the other side of that discomfort is a life that it's just, you know, the only word I have for it is lighter. There's like no better word for it. It's lighter. You just feel like you can move through like the waves of life with a lot more ease. You know, we've talked about financial investments. learning that your opinion and your needs should come first, this is the kind of personal and emotional investment that pays dividends and will bring you so much more happiness. I have a whole episode on this if you want to learn more about how to do that titled
但那种不适感的另一边，是一种生活，我能找到的唯一的词就是更轻松。没有比这更好的词了。它更轻松。你只会觉得你可以带着更多的从容穿梭于生活的波浪中。你知道的，我们已经讨论了金融投资，了解到你的观点和需求应该放在第一位，这就是那种能带来回报并为你带来更多幸福的个人和情感投资。如果你想了解更多关于如何做到这一点的知识，我有一整集专门讨论这个，标题是
How to Care Less About What People Think About You. It really breaks down an exact strategy that you can go about doing this. So go there after this if you need more tips. As we moved down this list, we're almost halfway through now. This next one sticks out to me particularly because it's probably one of my mistakes and probably one of my biggest regrets from this decade so far. Not keeping up with old friends. Now, it's true. You cannot keep every single friend that you have ever made.
《如何不在乎别人怎么看你》。它真正详细拆解了一套你可以用来做到这一点的具体策略。如果你需要更多的建议，看完这个就去听那一集吧。当我们沿着这份清单往下看时，现在已经快过半了。接下来这个对我来说特别刺眼，因为这可能是我的错误之一，也可能是这十年迄今为止我最大的遗憾之一：没有和老朋友保持联系。现在，这是真的。你不可能留住你曾经结交的每一个朋友。
But there have certainly been times when I've realized, you know, far too late that I really should have messaged that person back. I really should have answered their calls. I really should have kept in touch. And at some stage, you kind of, I guess, like months pass and you kind of wake up and you're like, wait, whatever happened to that person? And wow, they were a really good friend. I wish that I had appreciated them more. You know, you miss them, but you're at this weird point where you don't really know how to invite them or invite yourself, I guess, back into their life. friends as well kind of hold pieces of who we are and therefore as well who we used to be.
但确实有些时候，我意识到（为时已晚）我真的应该给那个人回信。我真的应该接听他们的电话。我真的应该保持联系。在某个阶段，你会有所察觉，我猜，几个月过去了，你突然醒悟过来，心想，等等，那个人后来怎么了？哇，他们曾经是个非常好的朋友。我真希望自己当时能多欣赏他们一点。你知道的，你想念他们，但你处在一个奇怪的阶段，你真的不知道该如何邀请他们，或者我猜，如何邀请自己重新回到他们的生活圈子里。朋友们也带着我们是谁的碎片，因此也带着我们曾经是谁的碎片，
So losing touch with them does sometimes feel like losing part of ourselves and that can hit especially hard during periods of loneliness or transition that obviously very synonymous with this decade. I remember when I first moved to Sydney, I've spoken about this before, I lost a lot of friends and I didn't really like appreciate how hard that was until later on. And now I'm at a stage where I really want to reflect. back on that time when they were present and I don't you know they're not there to do that with me and they're not there for me to learn from or to talk to and it's kind of lonely and it's kind of sad
所以与他们失去联系有时感觉就像失去了我们的一部分，在孤独或过渡期，这尤其具有杀伤力，而孤独和过渡期显然是这十年非常普遍的特征。我记得我刚搬到悉尼时，我以前也说过这个，我失去了很多朋友，直到后来我才真正意识到那有多难。现在我正处于一个阶段，我真的很想回想起他们还在身边的那个时代，而他们（你知道的）不在那里和我一起经历，他们不在那里让我去学习或交谈，这感觉有点孤独，也有点悲伤。
we have so much research out there I couldn't even begin to cite it that tells you that long-term social bonds are just as crucial for your emotional health and your physical health as so many other lifestyle decisions that we make so when we let those bonds fade you know it's not just about missing a friend. It's about really missing a grounding presence in our life and kind of missing out on all these like health benefits and like the secret to longevity. The secret to longevity is having people around you who love you and care about you. Please don't forget about that in the pursuit of your career or in your pursuit of love or in the current busyness of the life and the decade that you are in right now. Okay, we are over halfway through this listening.
我们有大量的研究（我都无法开始引用它们）告诉你，长期的社交纽带对你的心理健康和身体健康至关重要，就像我们做出的许多其他生活方式决定一样。所以，当我们让这些纽带消逝时，你知道的，这不仅仅是错过一个朋友。这实际上是错过我们生活中的一个坚实基调，并错过了所有这些健康好处以及长寿的秘诀。长寿的秘诀就是身边有爱你和关心你的人。在追求事业、追求爱情或在你当前所处的生活和这十年的忙碌中，请不要忘记这一点。好了，这期节目我们已经听了一半以上了。
now. We're going to touch on one more mistake that made the list, the early parts of the list, before taking a break. And it's different from everything we've kind of talked to. It's different from friendship. It's different from money. It has to do with our health. The biggest health mistake on the list was smoking. I wish I'd never smoked my first cigarette. I wish I hadn't started vaping. I wish nicotine had never entered my life. That was repeated time and time again. one person wrote in who was in their 50s and the way she found the podcast was that she'd listened to a few episodes with her daughter and she wrote into me when I was asking people for their biggest mistakes saying how she started smoking at 20 to impress a guy she got addicted and as everyone else around her slowly quit when they left for college when they had kids when they got married
现在。我们在休息之前，将探讨列入榜单——榜单前列的另一个错误。它与我们之前讨论的所有内容都不同。它不同于友谊，也不同于金钱。它关乎我们的健康。榜单上最大的健康错误就是吸烟。我希望我从来没有抽过第一支烟。我希望我没有开始吸电子烟。我希望尼古丁从未进入我的生活。这句话被一次又一次地重复。有一个五十多岁的人发来信息，她发现这个播客的方式是和她女儿一起听了几集，当我在向大家征集他们最大的错误时，她给我写信说，她二十岁时为了给一个男生留下深刻印象而开始吸烟，结果上瘾了，当她周围的其他人在离开去上大学、生孩子、结婚时，都慢慢戒掉了
she didn't and I have permission from her to share this but she basically said I've never been able to run more than a kilometer my kids have asked me multiple times, so many times to quit, and I know in my heart one day I'll get an unthinkable call from the doctor and it will be cancer. If only I was 20 again and I could reverse it all and reverse this decision. That kind of left me a little bit speechless, you know, hearing from someone, this big reflection on their life and almost this call, this like, it almost felt like she was like begging people in their 20s to just take their health more seriously. someone who could see what happens when you don't. And we can learn so much from stories like that. And yes, smoking is highly addictive. It's calming. You know, it looks cool. It's cultural. It's social.
而她没有戒掉，并且我得到了她的允许来分享这件事，她基本上说我从来没有能够跑超过一公里，我的孩子已经问过我好多次，无数次让我戒烟，我内心深处知道，总有一天我会接到医生打来的难以想象的电话，那就是癌症。如果我能回到二十岁，把这一切都逆转，把这个决定逆转，那该多好。这让我有点说不出话来，你知道的，听到有人这样深刻反省他们的人生，这几乎像是一种呼吁，就像，这几乎让人感觉她是在恳求二十多岁的人更认真地对待自己的健康。这是一个能看到不这么做会发生什么的人。我们可以从这样的故事中学到很多东西。是的，吸烟极易成瘾。它能让人平静。你知道的，它看起来很酷。这是一种文化，是社交。
It's also a habit that does damage that time cannot repair. And when you're young and healthy, you have the benefit of not having to think about that. But your oldest self is begging current you to think about them, to think about the future. to think about how you're going to feel when you really start to see the very dangerous side effects of this habit. Nowadays as well, you know, it's not just smoking. I also heard a lot about vaping. You know, for the first time in decades, I was looking at this research the other day.
这也是一种会造成时间无法修复的损害的习惯。当你年轻且健康时，你的优势在于不必考虑这些。但年长的你正在恳求现在的你去考虑他们，去考虑未来。去考虑到当你真正开始看到这种习惯带来的极其危险的副作用时，你会有什么感觉。而且如今，你知道的，不仅仅是吸烟。我最近也听到了很多关于电子烟的讨论。你知道的，几天前我看这份研究时，几十年来第一次。
The use of nicotine has like shot way up. Like there was this very steady trajectory over the years of like nicotine intake going down, going down with education, with people learning the consequences. But when vaping was introduced, you know, it's like this new thing. and with any new thing, there's not long-term research into the health consequences. And it was definitely marketed as like a healthy alternative and like something that wasn't as bad you as smoking. This is what I think about that.
尼古丁的使用量猛增。多年来，随着教育的普及、人们对后果的了解，尼古丁的摄入量呈现出非常平稳的下降轨迹，不断下降。但当电子烟推出时，你知道的，这是一个新事物。对于任何新事物，都没有关于其健康后果的长期研究。它绝对被作为一种健康的替代品进行营销，就像是一种没有吸烟那么糟糕的东西。这就是我对这件事的看法。
When people say like, oh, but smoking is so much healthier than smoking, I think like, that's like saying getting stabbed is a healthier alternative to being shot with a gun. Like, it might be true, but a knife still isn't going to have. feel great and it's still going to hurt and it's still not particularly good for you. So I would really encourage people who do vape and want to stop just to read up on the health consequences. We now are seeing studies come out. There was a 2023 study titled e-cigarette harms, aggregate evidence that shows damage to biological systems if you want to get nerdy and read that study. It's one of the first long-term ones that shows what is really happening to your lungs and your body when you vape.
当人们说，哦，但是抽电子烟比吸烟健康得多，我想，这就像是说被刀捅比被枪击是一个更健康的替代方案。这可能是真的，但刀拿在手里感觉依然不会好受，它依然会痛，而且对你来说依然算不上特别好。所以我真的鼓励那些抽电子烟并想要戒掉的人去了解一下相关的健康后果。我们现在看到相关研究出炉了。有一项2023年的研究题为《电子烟的危害：综合证据》，如果你想变得极客一点去阅读那项研究，它显示了对生物系统的损害。这是最早的长期研究之一，展示了当你抽电子烟时，你的肺部和身体到底发生了什么。
Wow, I feel like I'm like I'm like a health advertisement right now, but I'm going to take a short break now that I've kind of drilled into you a number of mistakes. I'm going to let you process some of them, get a cup of tea, get a glass of water. When we return, we're going to talk about mistakes related to family, taking risks, and why seemingly more people are seeing college as a mistake these days. So stay with us. You've heard the chaos. you can see it. Do we want to jump right in? Watch all your favorite podcasts from start to finish
哇，我觉得自己现在就像是一个健康广告，但在我给你们深入剖析了许多错误之后，我要休息一小会儿。我要让你们消化一下其中的一部分，去泡杯茶，喝杯水。当我们回来时，我们将讨论与家庭、冒险相关的错误，以及为什么似乎有越来越多的人认为上大学在如今是个错误。所以请继续收听。你已经听到了混乱的声音。你能看到它。我们想直接开始吗？从头到尾收听你所有喜爱的播客
right inside the free IHard Radio app. Make some noise. Oohie! Catch every laugh and eye roll on shows like Bestie Listen. Hey Jonas and Las Culturistas. Now with full video. I'll just leave that there. It's the same hosts and the same chemistry
就在免费的 iHeart Radio 应用内。制造点动静吧。哦！在诸如“Bestie Listen”之类的节目中捕捉每一个笑声和白眼。嘿，Jonas 和《Las Culturistas》。现在带有完整视频。我只想把这个留在那里。这是同样的主持人，同样的默契
with all the hilarious moments you've been missing right on your screen. Open the free IHard radio app. Search video podcasts and tap watch. What's up fam? I'm sports journalist Ari Chambers. Hey, what's up y'all? It's your girl, Sam J.
还有你一直错过的所有搞笑时刻，就在你的屏幕上。打开免费的 iHeart Radio 应用。搜索视频播客并点击观看。你们好，老铁们。我是体育记者 Ari Chambers。嘿，你们好呀！我是你们的女孩 Sam J.
And we're the host of everyone watches women's sports, a new podcast from Together and I Heart Women's Sports. Because let's be real. Women's sports is giving us way too much to talk about these days. So Kelsey Finler, she became the first female solo rower to go from California to Hawaii. My first thought is, like, what's up with the snacks? Like, what are we eating?
我们是《每个人都在看女子体育》（Everyone Watches Women's Sports）的主持人，这是一个来自 Together 和 I Heart Women's Sports 的全新播客。因为说实话。如今女子体育给我们提供了太多谈资。所以 Kelsey Finler，她成为了第一位从加利福尼亚独自划船到夏威夷的女性。我的第一反应是，零食怎么说？比如说，我们吃什么？
The highlights, the rivalries, the breakout stars, the moments to take over your entire timeline. in the conversations that start during the game and somehow keep going all week. Every week, we're breaking down the biggest stories across women's sports. Naomi Osaka showing out, she beat. Sabalinka.
精彩集锦、竞争对决、新星崛起、占领你整个时间线的时刻。以及在比赛期间开始、不知为何一整周都在持续的对话。每周，我们都在剖析女子体育领域的重大新闻。大阪直美大显身手，她击败了。萨巴伦卡。
Shout out to you, Naomi. You get the palm, Naomi. You get the palm for that. Because we're not just interested in what happened. We're interested in why everyone's talking about it. Because everyone watches women's sports. Listen to everyone watches women's sports. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast,
向你致敬，娜奥米。你拿到了奖杯，娜奥米。为此你实至名归。因为我们不仅对发生了什么感兴趣。我们对为什么每个人都在谈论它感兴趣。因为每个人都在看女子体育。收听《每个人都在看女子体育》。在 iHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 上，
or wherever you get your podcast. Hey, Portlandia fans. Seen and Fred Armisen here. You know us, or rather you know them. Tony and Candice, Nina and Lance, Spike, and yes, The Chicken. We've played a lot of iconic characters over the years, but today we're showing up as ourselves to tell you about Podlandia, AEO rewatch, our brand new podcast.
或在任何你获取播客的地方。嘿，《波特兰迪亚》（Portlandia）的粉丝们。Carrie Brownstein 和 Fred Armisen 在此。你们认识我们，或者说你们认识他们。托尼和坎迪斯、妮娜和兰斯、斯派克，还有，是的，那只鸡。这些年来我们扮演了许多标志性的角色，但今天我们以我们自己的身份出现，来向你们介绍我们的全新播客《波特兰迪亚：重温》（Podlandia, AEO rewatch）。
Each week, we'll revisit an episode of Portlandia from the very beginning, breaking down the sketches, exploring the backstories of our most iconic characters, revisiting the Portland locations you know and love, and opening up about our creative process. How did any of this get made? Why do we think that was a good idea? We're ready to talk about it. And we'll also be joined by the people who helped bring it all to life.
每周，我们将从头开始重温一集《波特兰迪亚》，剖析短剧，探索我们最具标志性的角色的背景故事，重温你们熟悉和热爱的波特兰拍摄地，并敞开心扉谈论我们的创作过程。这一切到底是怎么拍出来的？为什么我们当时会觉得那是个好主意？我们准备好聊聊这个了。而且将有帮助这一切成为现实的人们加入我们。
Guestrars, collaborators, and friends, including director Jonathan Chrysall, the mayor himself, Kyle McLaughlin, legendary musician Amy Mann, and many more. Kyle is going for it here. You fully improvised, not just words, but a song, a melody. Well, I thought he was going to write. I thought you were all going to write a song. I remember you thinking that. Listen to Podlandia.
客串明星、合作伙伴和朋友，包括导演 Jonathan Chrysall、市长本人凯尔·麦克拉克伦（Kyle McLaughlin）、传奇音乐家艾米·曼（Amy Mann）等等。凯尔在这里全力以赴了。你完全是即兴发挥，不仅是台词，还有一首歌，一段旋律。嗯，我以为他会写。我以为你们所有人都会写一首歌。我记得你是这么想的。收听《波特兰迪亚》。
Ayo rewatch on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I'm Nick Totoro. You probably know me from NYPD Blue, The Longest Yard, or Spike Lee's Black Klansman. But I'm also from Queens, which means I know pizza. And on my new podcast,
在 iHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 AYO 重温。我是尼克·托托罗（Nick Turturro）。你大概在《纽约重案组》（NYPD Blue）、《最长的一码》（The Longest Yard）或斯派克·李的《黑色党徒》（Black Klansman）中认识我。但我也来自皇后区，这意味着我懂披萨。而在我的新播客中，
delivering happiness with Nick Totoro, I deliver pizza from Prince Street pizza to a new guest. Are you delivering pizza now? Then we sit down for a real conversation. I've shared a slice with everyone, from Seth Rollins. What are you doing my belt? To Alex Rodriguez.
通过《与尼克·托托罗一起传递快乐》（Delivering Happiness with Nick Turturro），我将披萨从王子街披萨店（Prince Street Pizza）送到一位新嘉宾手中。你现在开始送披萨了吗？然后我们坐下来进行一次真正的对话。我与每个人分享过一块披萨，从赛斯·罗林斯（Seth Rollins）。你在对我的金腰带做什么？到亚历山大·罗德里格斯（Alex Rodriguez）。
Just to let you people know, we're talking to one of the goats here. To Bill Burr. I don't think I've ever met somebody so exactly out of their mind as I am. And now, we even have more great guests coming up, including the great John Tituro. It's called Happiness. Delivering Happiness. Mariano Rivera. Thank you.
只想让你们知道，我们这里在和一位史上最佳（GOAT）对话。到比尔·伯尔（Bill Burr）。我觉得我从未见过哪个像我一样精神如此错乱的人。现在，我们还将迎来更多伟大的嘉宾，包括伟大的约翰·特托罗（John Turturro）。这叫做快乐。传递快乐。马里亚诺·里维拉（Mariano Rivera）。谢谢你。
Oh, my God. And many, many more. Open your free High Heart Radio app. Search Delivering Happiness with Nick Tutro. And listen now. This is Chelsea Handler from Dear Chelsea. Every week, the news, gets worse. The world gets crazier and Yamanika is here to tell whoever's responsible,
哦，天哪。还有许许多多其他人。打开你的免费 iHeart Radio 应用。搜索《与尼克·托托罗一起传递快乐》。现在就收听。我是来自《亲爱的切尔西》（Dear Chelsea）的切尔西·汉德勒（Chelsea Handler）。每周，新闻都在变糟。世界变得更加疯狂，Yamanika 在这里告诉任何负有责任的人，
you're the problem. If you come over here to play games, I'ma check you. Okay? If you do some in the news that don't sound good, I'm gonna play you. Join Yomeneika Saunders as she breaks down the week's most problematic stories on her new podcast. You're the problem with Yomaniqa. Do you know I just found out who Sidney Sweeney was? New episodes weekly every Wednesday is part of my new network. the Dear Chelsea Network. If he got a bunch of women, then I should have a bunch of men. Do better or do less so I don't have to do so much.
你才是问题所在。如果你来这里想玩游戏，我会管教你的。好吗？如果你在新闻里做了什么听起来不太好的事，我会在节目里点名你。加入 Yamanika Saunders，在她全新的播客中剖析本周最具争议的故事。由 Yamanika 主持的《你才是问题所在》（You're the Problem with Yamanika）。你知道我刚刚发现西德妮·斯威尼（Sydney Sweeney）是谁吗？每周三更新新剧集，这是我的新网络的一部分。Dear Chelsea 网络。如果他有一群女人，那么我也应该有一群男人。做得更好或者少做一点，这样我就不用做那么多了。
So join Yamanika each episode as she answers one question. Who's the problem? I'm Yamanika and I'm out. Listen to You're the Problem with Yamanika on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. So our careers are probably, I'm going to say this, our biggest source of stress and anguish in our 20. you know, big questions to do with our careers. What's our dream job? Will I ever find something I care about? Like, how can I create the lifestyle that I want? Will I ever have a sense of purpose? Big questions, my friends. A lot of that starts with, should I go to college? Should I get an
所以请每一集都加入 Yamanika，她将回答一个问题。谁才是问题所在？我是 Yamanika，我先走了。在 iHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《你才是问题所在》。所以我们的职业生涯可能——我要这么说——是我们二十多岁时压力和痛苦的最大来源。你知道的，与我们的职业有关的重大问题。什么是我们的梦想工作？我会找到我真正在乎的事情吗？比如，我该如何创造我想要的生活方式？我会有使命感吗？朋友们，这些都是大问题。其中很大一部分始于，我应该去上大学吗？我应该获得
education? Or should I get my foot in the door career-wise and get experience and kind of not get a degree right now, but go back? The interesting thing that I found is that there was almost a 50 50 split, just in the people that DM'd me or reached out to me between the people who said college was a mistake and it was a waste of money and people who said, I regret not going to college and not prioritizing my education. It's very interesting and I think, obviously, you're probably listening to this being like, well, that doesn't help me. But let's have a little bit of a discussion around why people said college wasn't worth it and the people who said that they wish they had done it. I think these days, going to university just kind of seems like the necessary next
教育吗？还是我应该在职业上先迈出一只脚、积累经验，现在先不拿学位，以后再去读？我发现有趣的是，仅仅在私信我或联系我的人当中，认为上大学是个错误、是在浪费金钱的人，与那些说“我后悔没上大学、没有把教育放在首位”的人之间，几乎存在着五十五十的对半开。这非常有趣，我想，显然你听到这儿可能会觉得，嗯，这对我没什么帮助。但让我们稍微探讨一下为什么有人说上大学不值得，以及那些说希望自己当时读了大学的人是怎么想的。我认为如今，对我们许多人来说，上大学似乎只是必要下一步。但拥有一个学位，我们都知道这一点。这并不一定能保证你找到工作。甚至拥有硕士学位。甚至拥有博士学位，你知道的，这代价极其高昂。这是一项巨大的时间投资。它并不一定能保证你会领先或拥有更多机会。这就是为什么我认为很多人开始质疑其必要性的原因。就我个人而言，教育永远是有价值的。它是一项资产，即使这项资产被越来越多的人拥有。它赋予你的不仅仅是技能。仅仅身处那种环境中，你知道的，它能为你提供一个人脉网络。它为你提供导师。它让你接触到雄心勃勃的人，以及那些会成为你的朋友并帮助你取得成功的人。但是，如果你没有一个具体的
step for a lot of us. But having a degree, we all know this. Like, it doesn't necessarily guarantee you a job. Even having a master's. Even having a PhD, you know, it's incredibly costly. It's a huge time investment. It doesn't necessarily guarantee that you're going to be further ahead or have more opportunities. That is why I think a lot of people are starting to question its kind of necessity. Personally, I think education is always valuable. It is an asset, even if it's an asset that more and more people have. It gives you more than just skills. Just being in that environment, you know, it gives you a network. It gives you mentors. It exposes you to ambitious people and just people who will become your friends and will help you get ahead. But if you don't have a specific
想要做的事情，而你上大学或高校只是为了在清单上打个勾，你在课堂上并不投入，你没有Paying attention（注意力不集中），你并没有真正参与到那种体验中，你觉得自己完全没有动力，那它可能真的不值得。这就是有些人对我说的话。相反，比如进入职场、进行间隔年（gap year），这些可能在赋予你成熟度、经验和更明确的方向方面更有价值，它们应该被视为在任何阶段都值得去做的事情，而且在高中毕业后，去当学徒、去工作或者在高中毕业后去（你知道的）出国旅行，应该和直接
thing that you want to do and you're just going to college or university to tick it off the list and you're not being present in your classes, you're not paying attention, you're not really getting involved in that experience, you feel like you have no motivation at all, it might actually not be worth it. And that's what some people are saying to me. Instead, like going into the workplace, taking a gap here, those might be more valuable in giving you maturity and experience and more of a direction and they should be presented as things that are valuable to do at any stage but also straight out of high school it should be just as normalized to go and get an apprenticeship or to go on work or to go and you know travel abroad after high school as it is to just like jump straight
跳进大学一样被视为正常的事情。而且我和有这种感受的人交流过，你知道的，你在21、22、23岁醒来，你刚刚大学毕业，然后你意识到你已经花了19到20年的时间在学校里。就像，这是我从大学毕业时有的一种顿悟，我当时想，哦天哪，这是我生平第一次要度过超过三个月不学习、也不在教室里的时间。如果你在那段时期没有进行过一番灵魂拷问，并且如果教育是你所知道的全部，你会感到相当迷茫，并且你会感到
into university otherwise and i've spoken to people who feel this way you know you wake up at 21 22 23 you've just graduated university and you realize that you have spent 19 to 20 years being in school. Like, this was a realization I had when I graduated from uni, I was like, oh my God, this is the first time in my life that I'm going to spend more than three months not studying or not like being in a classroom. And if you haven't done some soul searching during that period, like, and if education is all you've ever known, like, you're going to feel quite lost and you're going to feel
有点害怕。所以这确实是需要考虑的事情。这绝对是我现在做的最好的事情吗？我无法替你回答，但请带着这些智慧，并用它去做你想做的事。我最近也一直很喜欢这样一种理念：人们在整个人生中分阶段享受退休生活，而不是只在生命的尽头才退休。将其常态化，不需要把所有的体验都攒到60多岁，而是在你的职业生涯和专业生活中去体验它们，进行短暂的间隔年，进行短暂的学术休假。而且，任何事情都可能发生。我总是记得别人给我讲过的一个故事：有一对60多岁的夫妇，他们
a bit scared. So it is something to consider. Is this necessarily the best thing for me to do right now? I can't answer for you, but just take that wisdom and do what you want with it. I've also been loving this idea recently of people who take their retirement throughout their life rather than just at the end of their life. You know, normalizing, not needing to save up all your experiences for your 60s, but having them throughout your career and throughout your professional life, taking little mini gap years, taking like mini sabbaticals. And, you know, anything can happen. I always remember the story I was told of this couple who were in their 60s and they
即将退休。妻子已经退休了。丈夫还没有。他一直说，哦，让我再干一年吧。我们还能多赚一点钱。再干一年，再干一年。然后我们就可以去，终于。为这次盛大、精彩的旅行攒够我们想要的所有钱。
were nearing retirement. The wife had retired. The husband hadn't. And he kept saying, oh, let me just one more year. We could just get a little bit extra money. One more year, one more year. And then we can go and finally. have all the money that we want for this big, amazing trip.
结果她心脏病发作了，在他们能够成行之前就去世了。你知道的，他离最终宣布“我退休了”只有六个月的时间，而她已经退休六年了，她却再也没有机会去做那些事情。这确实会发生。生活是非常不可预测的。所以，趁你还年轻、趁你还有时间、趁你还有去做的渴望时，去做你想做的事吧。所以这有点类似于我听到的另外三个常见错误，那就是人们后悔没有过间隔年。
And she had a heart attack and she died before they could do that. You know, he was six months out from like finally saying like, I'm done, and she'd been retired for six years, and she never got to do those things. And that can happen. Like, life is very unpredictable. So do what you want to do whilst you have the youth and whilst you have the time and whilst you have the desire to do it. So this kind of relates to three other common mistakes that I heard, which were people regretting not having a gap here.
人们犯了直接跳进工作岗位、并与自己的职业身份纠缠太深的错误，这使得他们很难辞去工作、辞去职业或退一步。以及第三点，人们觉得自己旅行得不够、探索得不够。而现在他们正处于安定下来的时期，并对此感到后悔。我们生活在当今的世界状态和社会中。它很大程度上由你的简历是什么样的、你取得了什么成就、你的职位头衔、你对拼搏（hustle）的奉献精神、你能向他人展现出多么成功来决定。要从中抽身可能会非常困难。
People making the mistake of jumping right into work and feeling too and messed with their professional identity so that it made it very hard for them to quit a job or quit a career or take a step back. And number three, people feeling like they haven't traveled enough and they haven't explored. And now they're in a period where they're settling down and they regret that. We live in a current state of the world and a current society. that is very much dictated by what your resume looks like, what you've achieved, your job title, your dedication to the hustle, what you can present as successful to others. And that can be very hard to step away from.
要从这种状态中抽身可能会非常困难，因为通常存在着这样一种潜在观念：如果你休息一下，或者为你个人的发展做点什么，你就会错过你职业发展的一个关键成长期。等你回来的时候，你已经错过了时机，你再也找不回那段时间了。你落后得太多，将永远无法迎头赶上。这是一个常见的误区。对此，我要说两点。建立你的职业生涯不是线性的。
It can be very hard to step away from because often there's this implicit idea that if you take a break or you do something for your personal development, you're going to miss out on a critical formative period for your professional development. And by the time you come back, like, you've missed the boat, you're never going to get that time back. You are falling so far behind you and never be able to catch up. It's a common myth. Here's two things that I'll say to that. Building your career is not linear.
一个人可能在五年内就能达到某个高度，而另一个人则需要三十年才能到达同一个地方。在那些年里，就你的人生经历而言，真正发生的事情才更重要，到头来也最重要。其次，如果我们回想一下临终之人的那份清单，那些有一生时间来审视和检视自己的人，他们列出的第二大遗憾，不仅是二十多岁的人，还有八九十岁的人都在说：我真希望我没有那么拼命工作。这些人有充分的理由保持诚实，他们拥有比我们多得多的生活教训，他们可能会愿意付出一切来换取第二次机会，用他们现在的智慧去生活。而他们把这份智慧赠予了我们。我们想要财富，我们想要成功。
People can get somewhere in five years, and it's going to take someone else 30 years to get to that same place. It's what happened during those years in terms of your life experience that matters more and will matter more at the end of the day. Secondly, if we think back to that list from people on their deathbeds, people who have their whole life to kind of survey and examine the number two regret they say, not just people in their 20s, people like in their 80s and 90s, I wish I hadn't worked so hard. These are people who have every reason to be honest, who have years more of life lessons than we do, who would probably give anything to have a second shot to live a life with the wisdom they have now. And they have gifted us that wisdom. We want wealth, we want success.
我们许多人想要这些的原因是，到头来我们可以去旅行。我们可以坐下来享受生活。我们可以拥有美好的事物。你现在也可以拥有它们。实际上，这是旅行的最佳时机。这是探索的最佳时机。你可能没有你想要的巨额预算，但你确实拥有年轻。你确实有机会创造非常精彩的故事，并培养会影响你更长时间的经历和技能。你是你这辈子最年轻的时候，很可能是最健康的。你精力充沛，没有那么多责任。老年人可能有钱，但他们没有你现在拥有的一切。
And the reason many of us want that is so at the end of the day, we can travel. We can sit and enjoy life. We can have nice things. You can also have them now. This is actually the best time to travel. It's the best time to explore. You might not have the big budget that you want, but you do have your youth. And you do have the opportunities to make really great stories and develop experiences and skills that will impact you for longer. You are the youngest you will ever be, the healthiest, most likely. You have the stamina, you don't have obligations. Older people may have the money, but they don't have all that you have now.
人们觉得他们犯下的另一个错误是没有冒风险，没有去追逐他们的梦想，与之类似的是，把时间浪费在思考而不是行动上。这真的让我想起了最近有人向我讲述的另一个故事，关于她的母亲以及她的母亲是如何训练成为一名会计的，她花了这么多年的时间努力成为一名会计，然后在职业生涯大约30年的时侯，她经历了一次彻底的精神崩溃，就觉得“我浪费了太多时间，我感到很不快乐”。她读了《艺术家之道》（The Artist's Way）——如果你知道那本书的话，她经常提到它——这本书太不可思议了。她读了《艺术家之道》，然后抛弃了一切，成了一名艺术家，现在她是一位非常成功的艺术家，
Another mistake people felt that they made was not taking risks, not chasing their dream, and in a similar vein, wasting time thinking rather than doing. This really reminds me of another story that I was told by someone recently about her mother and how her mother trained to be an accountant and she spent all these years working her way up being an accountant and then like 30 years into the career she was like had a complete mental breakdown and was just like I've wasted so much of my time I feel so unhappy she read the artist's way if you know that book do she references a lot it's incredible she read the artist's way and she dropped everything and became an artist and now she's an incredibly successful artist and
这个故事真正的寓意是她对我的朋友说过的一句话，这句话现在感觉已经永久地印在了我的脑海里：稳妥的选择之所以是稳妥的选择是有原因的，因为它将永远在那里，因为你随时可以退回原点。人们可不能对自己的梦想做出同样的保证。这是我绝对看到过的情况。你对生活抱有的宏大梦想，那些真正召唤着你的宏大梦想，它们并不总是会在原地等待。而且随着你年龄的增长，去实现它们的难度会越来越大。如果你想要一些研究来支持这一点——因为显然我不能一整期节目都不引用至少一篇论文——你得听听他们在康奈尔大学（Cornell）做的一项研究。所以这组
the real moral of the story is something that she said to to my friend, which now feels permanently, kind of see it into my brain, the safe option is the safe option for a reason, because it will always be there, because you can always go back to it. People can't always say the same about their dreams. It's something I've definitely seen. Big dreams that you have for your life, big dreams that are really calling out to you, they don't always wait around. And it becomes harder and harder to do them the older you get. If you want some research to back this up because obviously I can't just go a whole episode without citing at least one paper. You've got to hear about this study that they did at Cornell. So this team of
研究人员招募了数百名参与者来分享他们的遗憾，有点像我现在的做法，但更专业。然后，他们将所有这些遗憾及其回答分为两个不同的类别。那些涉及理想自我的遗憾，即你梦想成为的人，或是你感受到并渴望成为的驱动力；以及那些涉及应当自我的遗憾，即那些未能达到他人期望或理想的遗憾。你认为哪种类型的遗憾最常见？理想自我的遗憾以压倒性优势获胜。参与者对理想自我的遗憾，以及对那些他们希望通过做来实现梦想的事情的遗憾，要多于对他们希望通过做来给别人留下深刻印象的事情的遗憾，
researchers, they recruited hundreds of participants to share their regrets, kind of like what I'm doing now, but professionally. And they then divided all of these regrets and their answers into two different categories. Those involving the ideal self, i.e. what you dreamed you'd be or what you felt and in a drive to become and regrets involving the ought to self, i.e. those that dealt with not meeting expectations or the ideals of others. Which type of regret do you think was most common? Ideal self regrets won by a landslide. Participants had more regrets around their ideal self and around things that they wish they'd done to make their dreams come true over regrets around things that they wish they'd done to impress others
或是对那些他们因为“应该去做”而去做的事情的遗憾。所以数学概率是站在你这边的。如果你想减少遗憾，就为自己设定更高的目标。为了成为理想中的自己，多做一些事情。承担更多的风险，而且从逻辑上、科学上甚至可以说是显而易见的——你会作为一个更快乐的人、过着更快乐的生活死去。
or regrets over things they wish they'd done because they ought to have done them. So the math is on your side. Like if you want less regret, aim higher for yourself. Do more to become your ideal self. Take further risks and it kind of seems like logically, scientifically, I could even say, like you will die a happier person with a happier life.
好了，我们清单上的最后三个错误。它们都非常不同，而且都很难归入其他任何类别。它们是独立的遗憾。第一个错误是没有早点为我的心理健康寻求帮助。我经常听到这种说法。哦，天哪，如果我个人能时光倒流并告诉自己这一点，我想我会省去很多痛苦。你的心理健康是你最宝贵的资产。
Okay, we have three final mistakes in our list. And they were all very different, and they were all kind of hard to put into any of these other categories. They were standalone regrets. The first mistake was not getting help for my mental health sooner. I heard this quite a bit. And oh my gosh, if I personally could only go back in time and tell myself this, I think I would have saved myself a lot of suffering. Your mental health is your most precious asset.
人们说是身体健康。远不及你的心理健康，因为它源于大脑，而大脑确实控制着很大一部分。它控制着一切。如果你的大脑在受苦，其他一切都会受苦。它控制着你是谁、你对自己的看法、你的信仰、你的梦想、你的兴趣、你的人际关系，一切。所以请照顾好你身上的这一部分，把它当作它那样的宝贵资产来对待，特别是在你年轻的时候，因为如果你更早地学到那些能够伴随你、并在心理上带给你更健康生活的技能，你就可以学到很多这样的技能。
People say it's physical health. It's your mental health by far because it comes from the mind, and the mind really does control a whole lot. It controls everything. If your mind is suffering, everything else will suffer. It controls who you are, what you think about yourself, your beliefs, your dreams, your interests, your relationships, everything. So please tend to this part of you like it is the precious asset that it is, especially when you're young, because you can learn so many skills that will carry you through and give you a healthier life mentally if you
还要知道，无论你感到多么深陷泥潭，眼下的情况多么艰难，都有人经过多年的专业训练来帮助你度过难关。他们将能够帮助你度过难关。他们拥有成千上万的工具来帮助你感觉好点、找回自我。其中总有一种会奏效。所以，如果你一直在拖延，如果你一直在等待合适的时机，以为自己可以独自挺过去，基本上，不，你没必要独自承受。我听到的第二种常见的独立遗憾或错误是，没有问父母重要的问题，也没有花时间陪伴他们。在我们二十多岁的时候，我们会经历一个非常自然的与家庭分离的时期。每个人都会经历。这是我们发展中的一个重要阶段。
learn them earlier. Know that as well, no matter how stuck you feel, how hard it is right now, people trained for years to be able to help you through this. And they will be able to help you through this. They have thousands of tools to help you feel better and more like yourself. One of them will work. So if you have been putting it off, if you've been waiting for the right time, thinking that you can get through it on your own, basically, no, you don't have to. The second kind of standalone regret that I heard a lot or mistake was not asking my parents important questions and not spending time with them. When we're in our 20s, we go through a very natural period of separation from our families. Everyone does. It's an important stage in our development.
在发展心理学中，这被称为个体化（individuation）。你必须能够在远离家庭的安全感和结构的庇护下，形成自己独立的身份。但在某个阶段，确实会从这个时期走出来，你会重新回到父母身边，回到家庭成员身边，并以不同的方式看待他们。我认为你现在看待他们的方式，不是把他们当成平辈，而是把他们当成成年人，他们拥有复杂的生活，就像你拥有复杂的内心生活一样。你想更多地了解他们。你想更多地了解他们在成为父母之前是谁、在成为伴侣之前是谁、在作为孩子时是谁，所有这些事情。不要错过这个机会，不要错过这个窗口。
It's known in developmental psychology as individuation. You have to be able to form your own independent identity away from the safety and the structure of the family. But at some stage, do emerge from this period and you kind of come back to your parents and come back to your family members and see them differently. And I think the way you see them now is as not equals, but as the adults that they are with complex lives the same way that you have a complex internal life. And you want to know more about them. You want to know more about who they were before they were a parent, who they were before they were a partner, who they were as a child, all these things. don't miss that opportunity and don't miss that window.
我最近一直在和我自己的祖父母做这件事。我觉得自己很幸运，你知道的，我还有三个非常健康健在的祖父母，他们有着不可思议的故事。每次我见到他们，我都会努力说，你知道的，当我这个年纪时，你最喜欢吃什么零食？或者你最好的朋友叫什么名字？
I've been doing this with my own grandparents a lot recently. I feel very lucky that, you know, I still have three very healthy and alive grandparents who have incredible stories. And every time I see them, I really make an effort to just say, you know, what was like the snacks that you liked when you were my age? Or what was your best friend's name?
或者你从第一份工作中学到了什么？只是一些小问题，因为他们简直就像是一本教你如何过上好生活教科书。他们是一本我可以接触到的教科书，就摆在眼前、翻开着，随时准备让我去学习。很多人谈到失去父母，或者你知道的，发生了一些事情意味着他们无法与父母保持联系，这种感觉带来的错误感以及它是如何沉重地压在心头的。这个清单上的最后一个错误。我觉得这是一个最完美的结束地方。没有花更多的时间独自相处来了解自己。
Or what did you learn from your first job? Just like small questions because they are literally like a textbook on how to live a good life. And there are a textbook that I have access to that is like literally right there and open and ready for me to learn from. A lot of people spoke about having lost their parents or, you know, things happening that has meant that they can't really stay in touch with them and the mistake that really feels like and how that weighs heavy. The final mistake on this list. And I feel like it is the best place to end. not spending more time alone getting to know myself.
关于这一点，有趣的是，我从年长的人那里、从40岁以上的人那里听到这个错误的频率要高得多。以这个作为结束似乎是一个很重要的点。我在我的书中说过，我在我的播客中说过很多次，如果你经常收听，你可能会厌烦我再次提起。我提前道歉，但你一生中只会拥有一段关系。只有一个人。你与他/她相处的时间将超过世上任何其他人。
An interesting thing about this one was that this was one that I heard a lot more from older people, a lot more from people over the age of 40. It feels like an important one to finish with. I say this in my book, I say this on my podcast so many times that if you're a frequent listener, you're probably going to be annoyed that I'm saying it again. And I apologize in advance, but there is only one relationship that you will have your entire life. There is one person. You will spend more time with than anyone else in existence.
那就是你自己。你始终都在。你将永远和自己在一起。我非常喜欢卡尔·荣格（Carl Jung）的一句名言，那就是：人生的特权，是成为真正的自己。而这要从真正能够独自相处开始。为你的灵魂和自我意识照一面镜子并审视它，探索你体内那些让你感到不舒服的部分，尝试新事物，与你的思绪共存，与自己约会，
And that's you. You are always there. You will always be with you. There's a quote I love from Carl Jung, which is that the privilege of a lifetime is to know who you truly are. And that starts with really being able to spend time alone. to put a mirror up to your soul and your sense of self and examine it, explore the parts of you that feel uncomfortable, try new things, be present with your thoughts, go on dates with yourself,
只需了解你对生活的要求以及你是谁。这是一切其他事情得以建立的基础。我个人知道，要填满你的社交日程、没有一个周五或周六晚上闲着是多么容易，如果不这样做你会觉得自己很失败，我会有一种强烈的FOMO（害怕错过），或者总是和别人约会，当你这样做时，你最终拥有的安静时刻会让你感到非常害怕。事实上，当你练习独处时，你会意识到它是非常充实的，而且
just know what you want from life and who you are. It is the foundation upon which all other stuff is built. I know how easy it is personally to fill up your social calendar and to never have a Friday or a Saturday off to feel like you're failing if you are, I'll have this intense fomo, or to always be dating people, the quiet moments that you end up having when you do that will feel very scary. In fact, when you practice having time alone, you'll realize that it's very fulfilling and that
如果你能真正专注于你对生活的实际要求、你对人际关系的要求以及你对自己的要求，这才是过上好生活的关键。这是你不应该推迟的重要工作，它应该是头号优先级。榜单到此结束。这就是我们这份清单上的最后一个错误。我希望你从中有所收获。我希望你从中吸取了教训。肯定还存在着——人们还提到了很多其他错误。我绝不可能把每个人说的每一个小错误都包括进去。其中一些非常具体。但如果你认为有什么我们没有涉及到的重要错误，是你通过自己的人生经验学到的，请在下方留言。在剧集简介的下方留言。你觉得自己二十多岁时犯过的最大错误是什么？你认为人们可以从中学到什么？这种智慧是那种感觉非常、非常重要的智慧。我真的很喜欢能够研究这个，并只是，你知道的，某种程度上重温我的研究岁月。
it is the key to living a good life if you can really hone in on what you actually want from life, what you want from your relationships, and also what you want from yourself. And that's important work that you shouldn't put off that should be on. number one priority. That's where the list ends. That is our final mistake from this list. I hope that you've taken something away from this. I hope that you've learned from this. There are definitely probably, there were a lot more mistakes that people mentioned. Like, by no means was I able to include every single little thing that people said was a mistake. Some of them were very specific. But if there is one that you think we haven't touched on that is important
所以我希望你喜欢它。希望你喜欢这一集。把它分享给你认为也可能从中受益的朋友。留言、点赞、订阅，所有这些。事情也请留下五星好评。如果你觉得有必要的话，这确实对节目的成长、扩展以及接触新受众非常有帮助。同时确保你在 Instagram 上关注了我的账号 @thatpsychology podcast。如果你想为之后的剧集做出贡献，我在今天的剧集中学到和分享的很多内容都来自于私信，来自于那些在 Instagram 上关注我、能够做出贡献的人。所以我希望在那里见到你们。但直到下一次，保重。保持善良。对自己温柔一点。我们很快就会再聊。
that you have learned from through your own life experience, leave a comment below. Leave a comment in just below the episode description. What is the biggest mistake you feel like you have made in your 20s? And what do you think people can learn from that? This kind of wisdom is the kind that feels really, really important. And I really loved being able to investigate this and just like, you know, I don't know, kind of like revive my research days.
嘿，《波特兰迪亚》的粉丝们。Carrie Brownstein 和 Fred Armisen 在此。90年代的梦想在播客形式中依然活着。我们正在推出《波特兰迪亚：重温》（Podlandia, AEO rewatch），这是我们的全新播客，我们将一起重温每一集的《波特兰迪亚》，剖析短剧，深入探讨我们标志性的角色，并揭开这一切是如何制作的幕后花絮。
So I hope you enjoyed it. I hope you liked this episode. Share it with a friend who you think may benefit from it as well. Leave a comment, like, subscribe, all those. things leave a five-star review as well. If you feel cool to do so, it really does help the show grow and expand and reach new people. And make sure you're following me at that psychology podcast as well on Instagram. If you want to contribute to further episodes, a lot of what I learned and what I shared in today's episodes came from DMs and came from people who, you know,
而且将有帮助这一切成真的人们加入我们。客串明星、合作伙伴和朋友，包括导演 Jonathan Chrysler、市长本人凯尔·麦克拉克伦（Kyle McLaughlin）、传奇音乐家艾米·曼（Amy Mann）等等。凯尔在这里全力以赴了。你完全是即兴发挥，不仅是台词，还有一首歌。嗯，我以为他会写。我以为你们所有人都会写一首歌。我记得你是这么想的。
follow me on Instagram who were able to contribute. So I hope to see you over there. But until next time, stay safe. Be kind. Be gentle with yourself. And we will talk very, very. soon. Hey, Portlandia fans. Carrie Brownstein and Fred Armisen here. The Dream of the 90s is alive in podcast form. We're launching Podlandia, AEO rewatch, our brand new podcast where we revisit every episode of Portlandia together, breaking down sketches, going deep on our iconic characters, and pulling
收听《波特兰迪亚》。在 iHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 A.O. 重温。你们好，老铁们。我是体育记者 Ari Chambers。嘿，你们好呀！我是你们的女孩 Sam J.我们是《每个人都在看女子体育》（Everyone Watches Women's Sports）的主持人，这是一个来自 Together 和 I Heart Women's Sports 的全新播客。我们正在剖析最大的头条新闻。大阪直美，大显身手。向你致敬，娜奥米。病毒式传播的时刻。我一直沉迷于 Kashan Rock 的拳击之旅。她看起来状态很好。她的组合拳很敏捷。以及每个人都在谈论的故事
back the curtain on how it all got made. And we'll also be joined by the people who helped bring it all to life. Guest stars, collaborators, and friends, including director Jonathan Chrysler, the mayor, himself, Kyle McLaughlin, legendary musician Amy Mann, and many more. Kyle is going for it here. You fully improvised, not just words, but a song about it. Well, I thought you were all going to write a song for you. I remember you thinking that.
跨越整个女子体育领域。因为每个人都在看女子体育。在 iHeart Radio 应用上收听《每个人都在看女子体育》。Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方。我是 Jake Brennan。在我的播客《耻辱土地》（Disgraceland）中，我讲述了音乐界最大牌巨星背后的故事。比如，喷火战机乐队（Foo Fighters）的故事不仅仅关于音乐，它还关乎悲伤、震惊以及一切改变的那一刻。想象一下。你身处地球上最大的乐队中，就像 Dave Grohl 在1994年呆在涅槃乐队（Nirvana）时一样。电话铃响了。
Listen to Podlandia. A.O. Rewatch on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. What's up, fam? I'm sports journalist Ari Chambers. Hey, what's up, y'all? It's your girl, Sam J. And we're the host of Everyone Watches Women's Sports, a new podcast from Together and I Heart women's sports. We're breaking down the biggest headlines. Naomi Osaka, showing out. Shoutouts to you, Naomi. The viral moments. I've been obsessed with Kashan Rock's boxing journey. She looks good. Her combos are swift. And the stories everyone's talking about
你得知你的歌手、你的朋友、一个时代不情愿的代言人库特·柯本（Kurt Cobain）死了。在 iHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《耻辱土地》。我是来自《亲爱的切尔西》的切尔西·汉德勒。每周，新闻都在变糟。世界变得更加疯狂，Yamanika 在这里告诉任何负有责任的人，你才是问题所在。你知道我刚才发现西德妮·斯威尼是谁吗？如果他有一群女人，那么我也应该有一群男人。做得更好或者少做一点，这样我就不用做那么多了。
across women's sports. Because everyone watches women's sports. Listen to everyone watches women's sports on the IHeart Radio app. Apple Podcasts or wherever you get your podcast. I'm Jake Brennan. And on my podcast, Disgraceland, I tell the stories behind music's biggest names. Like how the story of the foo fighters isn't just about music, it's about grief, shock, in the moment everything changed. Imagine that. You're in the biggest band on the planet, as Dave Grohl was in 1994 in Nirvana. And the phone rings.
我是 Yamanika，我先走了。在 iHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《你才是问题所在》。我是尼克·托托罗。你大概在《纽约重案组》、《最长的一码》或斯派克·李的《黑色党徒》中认识我。在我的新播客《与尼克·托托罗一起传递快乐》中，
And you learn that your singer, your friend, the reluctant voice of a generation, Kurt Cobain, is dead. Listen to Discresland on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is Chelsea Handler from Dear Chelsea. Every week, the news gets worse. The world gets crazier, and Yamanika is here to tell whoever's responsible, you're the problem. Do you know I just found out who Sidney Sweeney was? If he got a bunch of women, then I should have a bunch of men. Do better or do less, so I don't have to do so much.
我将披萨送到一位新嘉宾手中。我与每个人分享过一块披萨，从赛斯·罗林斯。你在对我的金腰带做什么？到比尔·伯尔。我觉得我从未见过哪个像我一样精神如此错乱的人。现在，我们还将迎来更多伟大的嘉宾，
I'm Yamanika, and I'm out. Listen to You're the Problem with Yamanika on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. I'm Nick Tatoro. You probably know me from NYPD Blue, The Longest Yard, or Spike Lee's Black Klansman. And on my new podcast, Delivering Happiness with Nick Titoro,
包括伟大的约翰·特托罗。这叫做快乐，传递快乐。还有许许多多其他人。打开你的免费 iHeart Radio 应用。搜索《与尼克·托托罗一起传递快乐》。现在就收听。这是一个 iHeart 播客。人类出品，品质保证。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可留下评论。
I deliver pizza to a new guest. I've shared a slice with everyone, from Seth Rollins. What are you doing, my belt? To Bill Burr. I don't think I've ever met somebody so exactly out of their mind as I am. And now, we even have more great guests coming up,
我给新嘉宾送披萨。我和每个人分享过一块披萨，从赛斯·罗林斯（你在干什么，我的腰带？）到比尔·伯尔（我想我从没见过像我这样完全疯狂的人）。现在，我们还将迎来更多重磅嘉宾，
including the great John Tituro. It's called Happiness, Delivering Happiness. And many, many more. Open your free I-Heart radio app. Search Delivering Happiness with Nick Tutuil. And listen now. This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
包括伟大的约翰·特托罗。节目名叫《幸福》（Delivering Happiness）。还有更多精彩内容。打开你的免费I-Heart广播应用，搜索Delivering Happiness with Nick Tutuil，现在就收听。这是一档I-Heart播客，保证由真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。